give one like shout just like let it out
just one no that told you she's finally
here let's go
[Music]
see you america see you soon
i don't have butterflies i have an
octopus inside of me
we swiped right and i was like yeah
this is the the hottest girl i've ever
seen in my life please be real
[Music]
we just arrived in jail
finally i'm here in new york yes you
worked for me
[Music]
it looks so good
so good
she's chase she's getting weighed but
it's not about how she looks
i'll be coming to kansas city to spend
the rest of my life with you we've only
spent seven days together and we're
gonna get married does she really
love you for you and not joke honey
because you think you know somebody but
you really don't muhammad was completely
shredded
he's half my age but he said he wanted
to marry me he was a virgin wasn't
yes
you have a past
cheating on people
do you even trust me
i mean right now i don't even know how
do you not know we're getting married in
two days i mean are we
you told me
one thing's for sure you better not get
pregnant okay
damn babe you're ready
i can't even believe we are doing a
pregnancy test right now
oh my god
you told me oh you're wearing a bikini
you're naked i was not naked i don't
want to be judged i'm a grown-ass woman
you're going to be my wife are you going
to choose a bikini over me
so crazy drink i know chris in the
morning no no no no living with my
brother it's going to be
really awkward i live here too
i'm your family that's my family too so
you guys gotta figure out whatever you
come first living with his parents he's
definitely going to have to change i
feel like i'm being given an ultimatum
exactly
this bring up gives me a reality check
do you want to take everything that i
have
the person i fell in love with was the
guy i met in trinidad
company
we treat you like a sister but like you
don't treat me like a sister she don't
respect us she don't respect him and i
think she's psycho i'm not going to
marry you guys i'm marrying vinyam
[Music]
[Music]
you